[Música]
damos el paso a nuestra revista de
prensa con Rosa Pérez más deudor Rosa
Buen día para usted un día Ángela y
vamos a empezar con la que ha sido la
noticia titular desde ayer en la tarde y
son las portadas que destacan la
imputación de Donald Trump Exactamente
no se esperaba esta imputación pero
finalmente llegó ayer y hoy Abre las
portadas de la mayoría por no decir
todos los medios estadounidenses hemos
hecho una selección de cuatro periódicos
Empezando por los Ángeles Times que
titula Trump acusado un titular que se
repite en muchísimas cabeceras y también
la explicación de que se convierte en el
primer expresidente de Estados Unidos en
afrontar cargos penales también
encontramos exactamente las mismas
palabras en el Chicago tribun que
utiliza el subtítulo para hacer un
resumen del caso un Jurado de Nueva York
sigue adelante con los cargos sobre los
pagos realizados durante la campaña
presidencial de 2016 para silenciar la
historia de un encuentro
extramatrimonial el Houston chronical
también dice Trump a cargos penales y
señala el caso se centra en el pago de
dinero por silencio a una estrella porno
durante la campaña de 2016 la estrella
la actriz recordemos es stormy Daniels
quien quería vender a la prensa su hacer
con el entonces candidato a la
presidencia Donald Trump en 2016 y
cerramos este repaso de portadas con la
del New York Times que también Utiliza
este Trump inducted Trump acusado el
primer ex presidente enfrentar cargos
penales de nuevo se destaca nuestra
Primicia y dice el New York Times que
según Fuentes será consultadas por el
periódico El próximo martes Donald Trump
se podría entregar a la justicia ahora
bien Se espera que quedara en la
libertad digamos y también señala el New
York Times si bien los hechos son
dramáticos y la acusación explosiva una
condena está todavía lejos de estar
asegurada y hay quienes le dirían
incluso Rosa que esto lo que va a hacer
es Elevar la fuerza de su campaña
presidencial vamos al New York Times en
su editorial dice incluso Donald Trump
tiene que rendir cuentas vamos a ver
exactamente este editorial parte del
principio que Donald Trump se ha pasado
años tanto como candidato como
presidente ignorando digamos a las
normas no y que sin embargo este digamos
a este desprecio que ha tenido por el
sistema judicial no debe impedir que se
le niegue un proceso justo no pues que
ponga tanto en duda el sistema judicial
digamos en New York Times no ponen en
cuestión que las instituciones de la
justicia estadounidense no funcionen
sino que se refiere más bien a la
opinión pública no dice como hay que
preservar su presunción de inocencia y
permitir que tenga un juicio justo sin
embargo también dice por ser
expresidente no hay que otorgarle ningún
privilegio no recordemos que se discute
también si comparecerá digamos esposado
O no cuando sea finalmente detenido por
otro lado señala New York Times que hay
otras tres investigaciones preliminares
podrían tener mayor peso en caso de
convertirse en acusaciones formales
porque implican que Donald Trump habría
abusado de su poder como presidente una
de ellas recordemos es la que se
investiga en Georgia en la que se acusa
Donald Trump de presionar supuestamente
al secretario de estado de intentar
revertir el resultado electoral no
recordemos Esta es una investigación
preliminar como también la que se lleva
a cabo a nivel Federal sobre su
responsabilidad en el asalto al
Capitolio o la mala gestión de los
documentos clasificados que encontró el
FBI en la residencia de Mara lago de
Donald Trump por último este este
editorial del New York Times dice la
decisión de enjuiciar a un expresidente
es una tarea solemne particularmente
dadas las profundas fisuras nacionales
que Trump inevitablemente utilizará a
medida que se acerque su campaña para
2024 sin embargo el costo de no Buscar
justicia contra un líder que pudo haber
cometido estos crímenes sería aún vamos
a un cambio radical de tema Rosa Bad
Bunny protagonizó una portada de la
revista Time exactamente y digamos
también se le ha dado mucho bombo a esta
portada porque esta es una revista
emblemática estadounidense y es un
puertorriqueño no considerado por muchos
la mayor estrella de la música en estos
momentos y es muy destacable
precisamente el titular que se destaca
en esta portada de la revista Time que
es no voy a hacer otra cosa para que a
ti te guste no y destacable es que el
titular está en español porque una de
las cosas que dice Bad Bunny Que de
momento no va a hacer porque se lo pidan
otros es cantar en inglés y los
periodistas Andrew show y María espada
introducen así al cantante en 40 minutos
el que fue empacador en un supermercado
de Puerto Rico se probará prendas de
ropa que valen miles de dólares para la
portada de esta revista de aquí 12 horas
será fotografiado con la supermodelo
mejor pagada del mundo y en un mes
estará contemplando un mar de 125.000
fans desde las alturas del escenario
principal del Coachella atiende a esta
revista dice pensando en la casa de sus
padres en Puerto Rico fuera de esa casa
dice Bad Bunny Quizá el mundo me escucha
y habla de mí pero en esa casa todo
continúa Igual nada cambió Es hermoso
para mí ir allí ver que me siguen
mirando con esos ojos de Ben acaben y tu
Antonio el niño el hijo finalmente dice
Time Bad Bunny quiere ser el mayor
artista del mundo y lo es pero también
quiere ser solo Benito y hacer lo que le
da la gana y eso es lo que le ha dado
este éxito sin precedentes la lengua en
la que canta las posiciones políticas
que defiende los vestidos o las uñas que
lleva pues ver esta entrevista va a ser
una oportunidad para humanizar a la
persona que existe detrás del artista
Rosa y vamos a cerrar con una noticia
que hemos querido destacar y es la de
los ganadores regionales del World
exactamente que se han dado a conocer
esta semana hemos hecho solamente una
selección de dos fotografías pero pueden
verlas todas en la página web de este
concurso de fotoperiodismo en la región
de Asia hemos destacado la fotografía de
maba levin titulada el funeral de del
Mayo de 2022 el funeral de la periodista
de jazira asesinada según muchas
investigaciones independientes por
soldados israelíes y recordemos que en
el funeral las fuerzas israelíes también
cargaron contra los congregados en una
situación que casi acaba con el ataúd en
el suelo por otro lado en Europa hemos
se ha seleccionado la foto de edgen y
maloletka el asedio de mariupal en ese
momento recordemos que solo en un equipo
de ape estaba presente en la ciudad
asediada por las fuerzas rusas y las
fotos no de este equipo permitieron al
mundo ver los ataques contra civiles que
se daban en esa ciudad asediada del mar
Negro Rosa Que tenga feliz fin de semana
Igualmente Ángela